Alright, so you're familiar with the original Star Wars trilogy, as well as Jar Jar Binks and those prequels
[Hayden: what have I done]
You may have even seen the Star Wars Holiday Special
[Han: Would you look at Lumpy! He's sure grown huh?]
[Han: I think his voice is changing]
So where does Rogue One: A Star Wars Story fit into all this...I'm gonna tell you…
Let's pick up at episode...let's call it 3 ¾  with Star Wars Rebels.
It takes place in the latter part of that 19 year gap between Revenge of the Sith and a New Hope.
The show lays the foundation of the Rebel Alliance, focusing on a team similar to Rogue One’s outmatched heroes.
They put up a good fight against the Empire, but like a bunch of padawans versus Emo-Anakin, they don’t stand a chance.
[Hayden turns on saber]
See, the Empire had much bigger plans like building a super weapon space station capable of wiping out entire planets.
The Death Star had been under construction since The Clone Wars, but it was missing a fairly important feature… the whole planet destroying laser part
In retrospect, they also could have spent a little more time designing those exhaust ports.
[Luke fires missiles into Death Star]
Which brings us up to the events of Rogue Once prequel novel, Catalyst.
The book focuses on Jyn Erso’s father and super talented scientist Galen as well as Orson Krennic, an up and coming Imperial lieutenant.
Galen’s specialty is generating power through the use of kyber crystals.
Think of Kyber crystals kinda like Duracells for lightsabers.
[Luke turns on lightsaber]
Now imagine what you can build if you had a whole bunch of these crystals...
So good ol Krennic, eager to put a cherry on top of the Death Star sundae, brings Galen to Coruscant to work on a sustainable energy source.
Wink Wink
What Galen doesn’t know, he’s actually helping Krennic develop the weapons tech for the space station.
Being such a great guy, Krennic supplies Galen with piles of kyber crystals. But unbeknownst to Galen these were all taken from the lightsabers of dead Jedi.
Total dick move right?
when Galen finds out, he's not too happy
He and his family escape from Coruscant with the help of Saw Gerrerra, who’s the leader of a resistance group called the Partisans.
So when we catch up to Saw in Rogue One, we can assume that Jyn considers him a friend.
[Saw: The world is coming undone]
Speaking of Jyn - she’s all grown up, a quite rebellious badass with a particular grudge against the Empire.
She’s also the perfect person to lead a mission to steal the Death Star’s secret plans.
From Episode Four, we know that her team is successful in getting the Death Star plans to the Alliance.
but we don’t know who will make it out alive.
Do you have any theories on how the film will end?
Let us know in the comments and for all your film, TV and comic book needs keep it here on GameSpot Universe.